I can't wait to see you on Fallon
tonight hey what's going on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today we open up season seven with
Chrissy Teigen she's a TV host Twitter
juggernaut and best-selling author
speaking of you can pick up her latest
cookbook the highly anticipated cravings
hungry for more available online and in
stores now Chrissy Teigen welcome to
hello it's about time it is about I have
been hearing on Twitter for so long when
are you gonna do hot ones you know and I
had the same exact thing and I know that
you described yourself as a hot sauce
freak so I take it today's challenge
will be light work I'm a wing freak I'm
a hot sauce freak I'm a hot wing freak I
feel like we're gonna be okay but who
knows I've seen some episodes and
developing story just a few hours ago
you tweeted about your tongue being raw
from eating ruffles do you think that's
a disadvantage I definitely wasn't I
didn't think it through I mean I knew
this was gonna happen today and my
tongue nothing yes but a little hug
slightly yep hey it's not an excuse
though we only we're not even using that
as an excuse we're still gonna go for it
respect Chris he really good started his
season seven
[Music]
when you go to Hooters are they just so
excited red-carpet treatment so you're
not shy about calling it how you see it
which can be a real internet Viper's
nest when you're talking about food so
what I want to do is bounce some of the
most unpopular chrissy teigen food hot
takes off of you and just give you a
chance to defend them okay okay
why isn't it tell a trash oh oh I knew
that one was the first one for some
reason I think a lot of people actually
think that the hazelnut is good for them
and and they look it's like I oh I feel
I'm so French and uh no it's it's a you
eating chocolate in the morning it's
like I'm it's like the mimosa of foods
you just want to drink in the morning
which is fine but that's that's what I
have to say about you tell her did you
get any backlash for saying that Milky
Way's suck they are trash and yes I did
but nobody's like I just had one
everyone's like no it's not and I was
like when did you have it last they're
like oh that was four where do you stand
on deep-dish these days cuz you once
wrote a scathing blog post but I've also
heard you describe it as a topless
sexier calzone really listen we went to
Chicago I think I tried four or five
different ones I did follow my I respect
it for what it is it's not pizza
that's gonna be a bad thing that's good
so as someone who says she's hated party
since 1993 you offer a hilariously
honest window into award show culture
and people are so fascinated by these
clout festivals so if you'll humor us we
need a chrissy teigen guide to surviving
an award okay what is one thing that
actually is amazing about the VIP
experience of an award show and then one
thing that's not nearly as glamorous as
people think it is you still have dog
sniffing up your dress and stuff they
just assume that everyone is just
packing drugs at all times
um and you always think that people are
like partying and but no everyone is
just looking for the same drink base
they they're all like do you know the
virus do you know tomorrow's and it's
also very annoying cuz everyone wants
you in your seats so that when they see
you stand up to go get a drink they tell
you that there's no bar or are they they
try to lure you back into your seats cuz
obviously they don't want a whole room
of just seat fillers no and then from
the 2016 Oscars cringe phase to this
year's Emmys reaction you get meme drah
Lent lessly in the audience trying to
avoid a face by the way and it was even
worse because I don't know how to just
clap apparently I don't know how to do
it is it difficult just sitting there
knowing that any gesture any facial
expression could become a viral news
story well now they're looking for it
though which is what stuff like they'll
be um there when they do that camera
thing they're two feet in front of you
the red light turns on and that's what
makes me nervous I see that light go on
and then I'm like oh so stupid yes get
the light didn't come on I don't think
these faces would happen I get really
nervous
[Music]
so I'm take a wing to talk about your
cookbook and by the way shout out to
your editor Francis Lee a friend of the
brand we love fan that's just incredible
I know that you're a cookbook fanatic
yourself you'll bring in these huge
coffee table books onto planes
besides cravings 1 & 2 what are three
cookbooks you think everyone should have
on their shelf Oh God oh this is good
I'm gosh I think ina makes a beautiful
book and yeah she is always one my love
um I love Michael Symon's books him with
me it is just a beautiful thing oh my
gosh Momofuku Momofuku both David's book
and also Kristina's is just unreal can
you give me one idiot-proof recipe that
even an idiot like me can handle and
describe it as possible no really mm-hmm
oh my gosh my mom's Thai fried ribs for
sure it's truly you just take a slab of
baby back ribs cut it up toss it in soy
sauce maybe like 50 cloves of minced
garlic some like big chunks of pepper
and then let it marinate for 15 minutes
and then drop in hot oil and they just
get so jerky delicious my daughter loves
them yeah it's easy if you mess that up
you can't cook you can't because you
can't you can't put too much garlic in
it you can't put too much soy sauce the
only thing you could possibly do
you know it's you got it locked down the
idiot-proof alright Chris are you ready
to move on yeah I almost want to just
jump to the end we should have reversed
it one time petty Wong did that and if
he were here today he would tell you
that that was a mistake if you were
alive if you were alive today yeah so
this next one is the small ax peppers
habanero mango oh that kicked it up a
notch mm-hmm only issue is I'm getting
kind of full if I just licked on them
for a while would that be acceptable
well you know first hand how petty the
Internet can be so I think that that's
up to them like maybe they would think
like that was legendary its Morrissey
licked the wings I actually do cuz like
who cares if you take on white meat or
whatever I agree I think that you should
give that a shot okay so in this new
media clickbait economy there's this
trend where people take random tweets
from celebrities and then drum them up
into full-blown news stories yeah you
have any thoughts on that practice cuz
you seem to live under that microscope
and a few others do I have to love it
because it's why I am Who I am it's you
know that those kind of stories you know
gets me on shows like hot ones which is
great but yeah it is annoying because on
Twitter people follow you they know your
humor and then once that gets translated
into a story everyone's like leaving
comments like who cares I'm like that's
what I'm saying who cares it was just a
dumb tweet it wasn't meant to be some
kind of you know think piece let's work
put more on if I'm just licking cuz I
don't want this to be a thing later that
I didn't eat the wing uh yeah yeah if
that's what you want to do can I open it
sure and while you open that lets
workshop the title of this video right
now if the following which do you prefer
Chrissy Teigen as all of us while eating
spicy wings Chrissy Teigen drags her
haters while eating spicy wings our
Chrissy Teigen as mom goals AF while
spacing out um oh my god it is a true -
one of those is gonna be it isn't it
first of all I already know that Chicago
pizza thing is gonna come back and just
might mini ass cuz it bit me in the ass
five years ago damn it Christine Pizza
it's just not like dogs deep-dish pizza
while eating spicy wings would I go to
John's gonna perform in Chicago I'm
gonna get booed it's just all your
family is ruined
[Music]
whoa okay I'm just gonna talk there see
this is of course break a new ground
here on how I show no problem
Louis calientes light work hi Chrissy we
have a recurring segment called explain
that grammar we do a deep dive and I
guess Instagram put interesting pictures
that need more context so I'll bust out
the laptop I'll show you the picture
they tell me the bigger stories that
sound good
all right laptop please the Gillman of
hot ones that's a new nickname what do
you remember about the day that 14 uggs
took the mound and not a stadium I
remember it from these photos I think
was my dad's birthday and maybe like
this is like 10 to Keela shots in which
is a lot like that's I mean I remember
looking from the mound at the catcher
seeing three of them and then aim aiming
for the middle one that's a good way to
go yeah and I think we're just a foot
short I was really proud I remember
everyone thinking that it was a
reference to drugs they thought like
nugs like but that's like your go-to
order I'd sell 40 chicken nuggets
actually people got a no drug freeze the
way to be guys Nuggets what was a more
memorable experience for you
licking Padma's ear or licking the side
of my face we were just talking about
Aquafina day yesterday um I love Padma
I'm sorry no it's okay at her house on
her roof where my boob was out and I
didn't realize it
whoa yeah post you didn't show that one
you freed the nipple yeah I did but then
they took that down probably or no I
left it up I left it up they didn't take
it down no it's not what they had a
shear piece over it so I feel like it
wasn't just like colored in between the
lines there Christy thus concludes
explain that Graham are you ready to
move on I am from the back half of the
famous wing the Licking episode I'm not
gonna do the same thing oh good move
here my publicist like definitely hotter
mm-hmm
oh yeah
sounds hot say a woman of many passions
cooking hosting trolling but I'd be
remiss not to mention your love of
gaming if you were a video game
programmer and you can make two changes
to Mario Odyssey what would they be
Oh hmm that's a good question well I
never wanted to go back and do those
silver boxes that are everywhere you
know how those like open up new moons I
could never figure out how it's the my
fault though it's not their fault but
you can't do the extra jump like the
extra high jump they get then that
ruined like maybe 25 moons for me I
couldn't get I couldn't get to those
when you get frustrated or you a throw
the controller crack a screen kind of
person or do you stay on top of it I
throw it yeah I get mad there's some
levels on the when you're at the
when you're on the moon yeah there's all
these if you if you have to play it - no
but you have to like jump down and
there's a second level where it gets
real dusty and there's all these little
doors I can't pass any of those and I
remember throwing the controller a lot
of those I still I haven't my goal is to
get all the moon's but all I've done so
far is passed the whole game okay fire
water fire water fire water this is wild
Krissi thank you hands are shaking it
start okay [ __ ] yeah
so my guess is that sometimes neutral
and you expect to cause a little bit of
a stir but I imagine that there are
other times in the fire storm catches
you completely by surprise when you
think about all the niche interest
groups even sensed over the years be it
the man's sandal brigade and the clean
eating cult cyclists that was a big one
I was gonna ask who considers Chrissy
Teigen public enemy number one lists
absolutely yeah that was that was a
rough one for me I remember that like it
was yesterday
also people teams of people that
like those superstar protection tasks
yes yes listen that's a good way to put
it
can you tell me what was right in my
mouth too long I was showing off I was
like oh rinse it yeah remember early on
you're like these are easy these are
freebies these are first we might even
have them on here yeah that was like the
Scrabble free space and right and then
it's getting it's getting real yeah what
if any lesson did you take away from
nice bug gate is he a nice bug why do I
give him a kiss I'm stupid like I'll do
anything I'll touch anything like all
but yeah I shouldn't have probably
shouldn't I brought my kid into it I was
like Luna touch it but I had a lot of
entomologists and I'd love a nature
experts saying that it was very good for
me to teach my daughter that all things
are living and breathing and beautiful
and even if they have some sort of
paralyzing venom you know yeah we're all
creatures on this space Rotel was
apparently watching my instagram too and
they like ran over on a golf cart and
they were like don't play with the hose
I would suggest not pointed um I heard
about this one yeah
that's right let it go oh I would I'll
burp - too acidic okay you can't be
careful be careful oh that does even
smell like food yeah oh my god yeah I
would maybe just just get along okay
okay
no because that I don't want to just win
this is season opener yeah they just set
the bar did you have that chip yeah the
pocket chip the world's hottest my mom
ate it like it was nothing really I
thought that was super spicy did you
have that yeah corner of it okay oh
that's funny that's plain that's good
let's go um can't be careful really I'm
telling you
[Music]
poof mm-hmm that's smoky it's almost
like a mezcal my god yeah oh and then
you down mm-hmm
all right Chrissy your career touches so
many different spaces so what I want to
do is hit you with some career
accomplishments and I'm just curious if
it's a highlight if you don't give a
[ __ ] I'm just explaining is that sound
good okay receiving your lifelong dream
Christmas gift of an entire wheel of
cheese at the time it was really it
ranked way up there
so important to me didn't have a fridge
for it it went bad in within days being
briefcase model number 12 on Deal or No
Deal just horrible but I love talking
about it because it's so stupid and I
didn't even I got fired I couldn't do
the briefcase thing like I got fired
yeah so much worse you got fired from
Dylan no deal I got demoted so I was a
briefcase girl where do they send you
I became a banker girl and you wear like
a Robert Palmer outfit in the black with
the red lipstick doesn't make any sense
thank you shake it yeah listen I'm not
uh I'm no superhero yeah grab some those
kids how about you and John topping a
poll of celebrity couples people would
most like to have a threesome with I
love that because that means that we
project this sexiness that we don't
really have project have we have it but
I think one of my questions
yesterday was oh how hard do you guys go
at it after the II got it was like not
hard all right Christy you're ready to
move on ah [ __ ] that one sucked
yeah [ __ ] that one Ellen's no good okay
she's bad little casual with the poor
okay what is exha Resco mean I don't
know we've been debating even how to
pronounce it internally this seven pop
Remo considered one of the hottest
peppers extreme heat but also
exceptional flavor use liberally check
that box
Colorado I have family in Colorado in
Durango hi Durango hi Cassie Brian Cindy
here we go it's going down I'm gonna
bite it and eat all the part
whoa that's different hot alright so one
of the things I think people appreciate
about you is that you approach leisure
time with great gusto and don't
exclusively engage in these basic
celebrity behaviors like going to Nobu
Malibu and pretending to ski in Aspen so
I'm curious what to you is a better
night out Wrestlemania or medieval times
oh wow just talking me to Curt hmm
middle times an amazing turkey leg and
their tomato soup these ones it's fine
until you talk it's good thing we made
an interview show around as you know if
you are stuck on a desert island with
only one show to binge what would it be
that's the milk I think no blow duck
[Music]
can't wait to see you on Fallon
[Music]
alright Chrissy
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
but I would say you know we've come this
far
yeah and you know what I'm gonna do I'm
in a little hole I'm gonna put on a
little and smear it right along with you
they'll be so cool if you got if the
last one ended up like everyone's like
[ __ ] and then you end it stick just like
it's like ice cream yeah like maple
brown sugar right right
[Music]
it's not know lest you had any thought
the trick it's delicious it's amazing
chocolate pepper just a good strong
healthy Cody okay he'll eat so it's
going down I could see here we are at
the final stage your cookbook is full of
serviceable tips and tricks for the
aspiring home cook the hardest things
that people do one of the biggest
mistakes that people make is in pitting
in avocado yeah I know that you have a
whole page breaking it down in your book
but how can you do it with a bajillion
scovilles coursing through you
Chrissy could you talk through the steps
okay
I use a passion of mine pitting avocados
yeah just
I call it Instagram pity it's not the
way I would do it in real life if I'm
just making a salad or something
ah I have a clean knife take out piccata
[Music]
turn-turn
give it like a gentle but but be patient
take your time there we go
he was just the tip
[Music]
yes there it is
beautifully played that beautifully cut
beautifully Pitt Chrissy Teigen running
the hot wings gauntlet in a way that
only Chrissy Teigen can and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you you legend this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
I got to say it mm-hmm cravings hungry
for more is out now at bookstores
everywhere or no everywhere that carries
books important distinction around
cravings collection my home wares
collection is available exclusively at
Target and you're gonna love it
hmm Wow not [ __ ] monster the bomb I am
I don't know if I'll ever be the same
after da bomb you guys someone has to
try this
1 million - 1 million 3 that's pretty
good form Phil then you get that cool
shirt
you didn't hear how ones merch it's
available now I thought you only wore
Where's Waldo shirts I used to wear
where all their shirts one
[Music]